alright this is a pepper panic saga
level 85 Walker video this is a lot of
people that a level but a lot of people
get stuck on you have a low number of
moves and you have to open up this board
in order to collect all these orders and
it's pretty difficult to do if you don't
get a good start what you're trying to
do in the beginning is free these two
red peppers from the eye so that you can
make these two matches and open up the
board so you have to make matches in
this small area here and you don't have
a lot of choices but you just want to
try to look for matches that'll clear
two rows or two columns at a time or
whatever like here I can move the red
one up and that will clear out both of
these the reason you do that is because
a lot of the explosions that you get
will come from when the peppers drop
into the board and you don't have enough
moves to actually if you don't get some
help to actually complete the level so
I'm going to move this one up nothing
really exciting happen there
and like right around here when you get
to because you're going to use up two
moves to open the board right around
when you get to here it's going to be
really difficult to finish the level and
you can see we didn't make any mistakes
or anything we just didn't get a good
drop on as they fell into place but
that's the last explosion that we needed
and so now the red peppers are free up
here but because it took so many moves
by the time we make our two top moves
really going to have three left so you
have to match the green side first the
reason you do that is because that grows
this yellow pepper big enough that when
you match it it will explode you can see
the green ones it and explode and when
it explodes it opens up the less you're
bored at the bottom you want to get a
pepper panic here I mean there's no way
that you can influence that right on
that's another thing that can happen
that can make it tougher than the normal
as if you if you don't get a reaction
rear okay so when you have a few more
moves these these decisions here can be
the difference between completing it and
failing since we don't have a lot of
moves and the board isn't set up while
you can see we have yellow peppers which
you're useless mixed in in the area we
have one stage five red pepper but we
don't have anything to match it with so
you know our chances are pretty low
completing a level right here there's no
big match down here that's going to like
open up the space immediately so I'm
just going to go ahead and explode this
red pepper I did it vertically because
that bring a few
more peppers in and then I'm going to go
ahead and go down here and as you can
see there's just some chance there's
just some attempts where you're not
going to finish this level so we'll fire
it up again
and see if we can't get a faster start
alright same strategy
alright so we did catch one drop there
we might get another words girl okay so
that's much better we got one hit and we
have another explosion set up so when
you're able to open up the board this
fast this is where you really have to
make things count you won't be able to
do it every time so when it does happen
you want to really pay attention to how
you make your choices if you remember
last time we had three moves up this
time we're going to have six and like I
said hopefully we'll catch a pepper
panic right here and pick up some of our
blue orders as well
oh yeah we must we might as well get a
second one while we're at it
that can happen from time to time it you
know it won't happen often enough that
you can actually count on it but because
the way the board is set up you know
there's you know it happens often enough
all right so now we have just a great
chance of finishing we have to get two
more pepper panics nine explode nine red
peppers explode eight blue peppers and
we have six moves scanning the board
there's not really that no color
actually stands out as being the best
one to go with we have a couple stage
fours but they're not at the same color
since we have the extra moves I'm going
to make this out first just because
there's no real action moves down here
and this will clear out a decent amount
of space and we might catch something
else whatever peppers fall down and it
didn't but but that's fine i'm going to
go ahead and match the purple here
because it's also going to make the blue
man and then that you see that drops the
the red and into place
and those little decisions are really
where the you know where company and
whether you end up finishing it or not
finishing it you have to really look
around and see what's going to happen as
a result of each one of your matches all
right so now we just need one more
pepper panic and six red peppers there's
not a lot of red peppers on the board
and none of them are grown except for
these ones right here so that gives us
an interesting choice because we can we
can match the red with a shockwave
they'll clear out a little bit of space
but it's also going to remove one of our
grown peppers or we can match it here
and that will explode this pepper and
grow it again I think since its not I
think in most cases if we had more grown
red peppers on the board then this would
always be the best match because we have
a better chance at a chain reaction but
since this is kind of jumbled up i'm
going to go ahead and make the this the
big match and clear out the column
another thing to keep in mind is like
with only five red to explode we can
really start a panic with any color we
don't have to to focus only on that the
reality is on the in this current
situation though that there is no other
better color to work with this time I'm
going this time I'm going to make this
match for the same reasons I mentioned
before it'll drop some peppers in the
space it won't disrupt this and this
will be the quickest way to get things
going okay so now you see we have 255
state stage box sitting on the board and
then we have a couple other grown ones
here so now by exploding this red one we
should get a good chain reaction and
instead of just moving that red one down
I'm going to go ahead and match the
purple does that just gets a little bit
more space and makes it more likely that
other things to happen is risen
and that's how you do it obviously it
helps a lot to get those first couple
explosions with the red peppers quickly
that being said you can you can complete
it with less less moves but you know you
really have to think out your moves
afterwards because it's not likely to
finish it by luck as far as just moving
a random making random matches and
hoping things fall into place where you
really do have to to think your way
through that last part and you know that
like we said in our full pepper panic
saga level 85 guide at pepper panic tips
that's that's the only part of the level
where you actually have control the
beginning part other than clearing the
maximum amount of space with your
matches there's really nothing you can
do to improve your chances there's going
to be times when you get good drops so
there's going to be times when you get
bad drops so focus on what you can and i
hope you complete the level soon it's
really not as bad as it seems at first
but you need a little bit of help from
the peppers and you need to make good
decisions alright thanks